don't ask me to do any trapeze when you
see because it's not gonna
i don't have it anymore which major
spider-man stunt did zendaya film
only to have it cut from the movie today
we're taking a look behind the scenes at
what it was like for zendaya to film
so many of her own stunts which trap
he's stunt gone wrong led to a very
awkward moment between
zendaya and zac efron and the greatest
showman which film did zendaya swing
from
over a hundred feet up there is one
thing we got to do
this big spidey swing through new york
zendaya and tom holland are
definitely comfortable getting cozy
considering all the major swinging
stunts they've had to do together
the on and off-screen power couple have
some major jumps together in spider-man
3.
while filming the two were recorded
performing a very impressive high swing
in a field
when the actors were shooting spider-man
far from home one of the biggest stunts
they did together was a sort of
spidey swing through downtown new york
city zendaya and holland were lifted
over a hundred feet in the air
and then performed the enormous swing
over a huge pile of empty boxes
why we're not too sure and zendaya
herself is a bit confused by the process
but says it works anyway
there's like these empty boxes stacked
together and i was like
this is a pretty big stunt to do for any
performer
much less an actor who doesn't
specialize in stunts
although after this and all the other
times she's shown off her stunt skills
on screen
we think she's pretty well versed in it
all in an interview with stephen colbert
zendaya said that the experience was
amazing and she was really proud of
herself for doing it was a big swing
yeah that's something we can all agree
on
while the experience was intense and
exhilarating it turns out
it was all for nothing the footage they
shot didn't end up being used for the
film and
instead the actors actually had to
reshoot the whole thing
it might have been a better situation if
they got rigged up again and did the
stunt but
instead the actors were held up with
wires
but about 98 feet lower than they were
the first time
yep the performers did the impressive
giant stunt swing
only two feet above the ground while
according to zendaya
the director said okay scream and then
would pull the actors
arms swinging their bodies and
shockingly that footage worked even
better
it looks great in the movie and holland
and zendaya definitely pull off acting
like they're flying through the air
chances are experiencing the real thing
probably helped them with that
it seems terrifying but according to
zendaya herself
it's super fun zendaya isn't just an
amazing actor
she's also a surprisingly good trapeze
artist
when the actress was playing anne
wheeler in the greatest showman
she performed most of her own incredible
stunts the actress once said that she'd
never thought she'd do any kind of
acrobatic work before in her life
so this role was a quite literal leap
before filming even began the then 21
year old zendaya received
phone call from director michael gracie
telling her to start
building up her strength and working out
since he wanted her
to begin her trapeze lesson soon started
you know building
upper body strength which i don't have
and have not maintained either not only
did he want zendaya to be proficient
enough to be convincing on screen in the
role
gracie told zendaya he wanted to use the
stunt double
as little as possible when filming it
was it was a lot of training a lot of
just literally getting up there just
going for it the entire cast actually
rehearsed similarly to the way a
broadway production cast would
so the work began way before filming
even started
zendaya's early days were spent training
but eventually
she dove right into the work from the
deep end to see what she was able to
pull off on the trapeze
as it turns out she was capable of a lot
one time in particular tested zendaya's
nerves she'd come to set ready to do a
big trapeze stunt and when she arrived
she got a bit of a shock the rig she was
going to be on was about
20 feet higher than she thought it was
going to be to make things even worse
there wasn't even a net underneath
that's a little
that's a lot to get over that's right
the actress was going to perform a
tricky trapeze stunt for real
and it wasn't going to be as easy as
diving into all of her training
beforehand
while zendaya knew she'd be rigged up
and extremely safe
she hadn't been so prepared for it to
feel so intense
however just in the nick of time hugh
jackman came to the rescue
zendaya shared that behind the scenes
jackman came over to her while she was
on set
ready to go up in the cherry picker and
told her that she was a badass
turns out that was all the help she
needed and i was like
take me up after being called that by
the hugh jackman
zendaya felt like she could do
absolutely anything so
she eagerly went up in the cherry picker
to take her place at the top of the
circus tent
ready to dazzle and impress she wound up
loving it in the end
and was really grateful that she got to
do it for the role since it's not really
a discipline she would have picked up
otherwise
i never thought that i would be doing
any type of acrobatic
trapeze work in my life it wasn't all
magical aerial tricks and confidence
boosters from hugh jackman though
zendaya and zac efron had more than a
few mishaps together behind the scenes
we know it's hard to believe considering
how elegant and romantic they look
together on screen
but sometimes they really missed the
mark
zendaya and defront were practicing one
of the aerial tricks they performed
together
you know the one the iconic swinging
around the ring scene
as we can see in the movie they
gracefully grab onto each other but when
rehearsing
instead of the elegant trick they miss
their marks and the two of their bodies
wound up just
awkwardly swinging into each other and
totally stopping the motion the result
was
two deadweight bodies hanging limply
instead of romantic circus magic
and that's just one of the many this
particular trick
definitely took a lot of practice but
considering the final product
we'd say it was worth it the pair
actually did
multiple takes of a number of their
scenes according to zendaya herself they
would often ask to do more takes after
the rest of the team was happy because
they wanted it to look perfect and if
there was any chance of improving what
they'd done
they wanted a chance to shine again
luckily zendaya was acting opposite zac
efron who adored working with her
she's just incredible the two were
always checking in on each other and
making sure the other was taken care of
pretty much a dream working relationship
their chemistry is
off the charts and probably because of
how much of a team they became
zendaya described them as strapped
together figuratively
and literally in order to perform all of
their risky stunts
zendaya explained that there had to be a
certain amount of trust and connection
both of which definitely shined through
on screen these rules were absolutely
hard on their bodies
zendaya once said that she got a lot of
bruises and was
constantly sore but it was totally worth
it
her love for the experience is pretty
obvious especially considering the fact
that even when she wasn't filming
the actress could often be seen hanging
around on set watching what was
happening because she enjoyed being
there
so much it literally placed everything
that i love
there was a lot of action in euphoria
but no doubt
one of the most interesting and
mind-bending was the rotating room scene
for zendaya while she agreed it was cool
it was
really intense and she explained it was
a very disorienting process
the actress was very much experiencing
the wild journey her character rue was
on in real time
you have no sense of where the real
world
is while it wasn't an easy experience to
shoot for her
zenday was also feeling lucky not to be
the people at the party who were
literally strapped down in place and
rotating with the whole room
the contraption had actually been built
and made to rotate while zendaya walked
straight through
behind the scenes she empathized with
what she imagined was a
very intense headrush for the rest of
them i did not envy those people
we already loved zendaya but seeing just
how much work she does and how many
skills she's developed to pull off these
feats while performing each of her roles
is beyond impressive her commitment to
the craft shows and it definitely adds
to the characters she builds and
portrays
would you try any of these stunts